so I'm Dan Fernandez so while I'm
currently on the Azure demikhov comm
team one of the key things you know I've
been working on Microsoft for like 18
years it worked on c-sharp Visual Studio
docker tools as your CKD jeff sink was
at one point said hey we got a fix
MSDN and TechNet how many of you used to
have ever been to MSDN and TechNet okay
a good show of hands and how many of you
have been to Docs or use Microsoft learn
any couple of more hands edited a doc
meaning community contribution to any
kind of doc couple hands up and how many
of you know how to raise your hand when
asked ok about half the room ok good so
that's awesome we're going to talk
through a number of the different things
that we did here and it's kind of a
story of conflict murder like we killed
MCN not actual murder and redemption in
hope so I'm going to go ahead and get
started all these slides are available
I'm not going to talk through everything
here we'll make available just you have
it as a reference so here's what we're
gonna talk about why do we even care
about this space a new hope our
Redemption story get into architecture
how do we build something when we need
it to hit global scale and right now I
think our number is 50 million unique
customers a month or 200 million page
views a month and how do we do that in a
performant and cheap way using Azure how
we actually do a documentation so your
edit all the way to website we'll go
through that how do use github and then
some of the unique challenges with
building things like API reference and
Microsoft learn cool so exciting I know
I know it's standing room only geez
there's a couple sheets over here if
you'd like okay so why why do we even
care about do we care about
documentation
who cares about right like this is kind
of a common thing where it's like all
right we're gonna ship and then worry
about this later
but it turns out all of you care so when
they do surveys this is slash data in
the 2017 and 2018 numbers are
goal documentation and sample code is
the number one most important thing to
the developer audience the number one
thing
tutorials which is number two when you
click into that it's step by step
learning right I'm going to start at
zero and build something when you look
at d-zone besides after the API which of
course you know if you're developer if
you don't have an API yes documentation
is going to be number two but it's the
number two most important thing on the
left hand side what you're seeing is
open source developers this is the
github survey that says the number one
problem in open source is documentation
and it's not just an open source thing
it's an enterprise thing so Gartner
group which does their Magic Quadrant
when we took over it they would call out
why Microsoft is inferior to AWS and to
Google cloud platform customers site
issues with documentation and training
this is enterprise open source the
developer ecosystem in general and again
miguel which has the most impact today
sit down and write documentation so is
it important yes yes it is so how do we
get to this state so embassy on and
TechNet has been launching cds anybody
still have those cds or remember yeah
exactly they're great on ebay aren't
they so we've been doing this for a
while I missed yen started as a web site
around I think it was like 94 a couple
years later then TechNet followed and
you know it was where we publish all of
our documentation but it was only
documentation writers proprietary
formats it was really hard for you to do
and this thing happened in between there
and maybe you all saw it
blogs when blogs happen all Microsoft
employees started blogging because it
was that much easier to publish content
and when I say all Microsoft boys we had
16,000 instances of blogs why because
this could not scale what also happened
is teams had business requirements right
so like you're not even getting to my
change it it takes too long to get my
stuff on the web this is just a sampling
of all the sites that existed when
we started this effort right so many of
you know asp.net had its own
documentation on asp.net asp.net core
had its own separate documentation using
read the docs so even teams you know
within just the asp.net team they had
two different stacks for doing
documentation scary so what we decided
to do was interview a number of
customers which is kind of that middle
column and you know we have reams and
reams of data we wrote an eight page doc
we stole Star Wars Episode four and
called it a new hope right because it's
not often you say we need to do a total
rewrite but that is what we said we need
a 10x better experience and we need to
treat dogs just like OSS code we have a
huge problem if you are a web developer
that wants to build something on adjure
with the database you're going to five
different websites entity framework
there Doc's were in there hidden in
their github repo asp.net corbs over
here sequel well it depends sometimes it
was TechNet sometimes it was MSDN we
don't even know how right this is this
is the world we live in one of the key
things to when you're doing these
projects is to measure the business
outcomes which is what are you trying to
do our Doc's will help you get there and
this was one of the areas where people
again just kind of ignore Docs and the
importance of Docs all of us at some
point had to evaluate between a B and C
technology and you do the Pepsi
challenge you open up a browser you open
up a bunch of tabs and you're choosing
between which one is which maybe you
look at some third-party independent
things this is what our customers did
and they land on these MSDN pages the
samples don't work it's out of date it's
incorrect or they can't find it they're
not going to choose us right there it's
directly tied and we started adding ways
to measure this through analytics and
then we had what's called mom Jennifer
Meshkov scanner team had the mother of
all migrations which is 45 million
documents that they had to migrate from
MSDN and TechNet either migrate archive
or retire and when I give you kind of an
example Visual Studio what they did is
every release they copied every single
dock so visual studio 2008 25,000 Docs
2010 2012 2013 2015 they're all the same
dogs and in many cases that Doc's
haven't even changed right but we
literally have copies of these things
which actually ruins our SEO and a
Visual Studio 2012 for whatever reason
had the highest SEO so nobody could even
find the 2015 Docs I know many of you
who have kind of faced this so
unreadable URL this is my personal
passion our URLs were terrible so
there's just a number of things that we
really wanted to do it and prove here
and we got approval and by off to do
this and one of the key things though
that we wanted to do was set boundaries
so we're not going to be some white
label documentation solution where
everybody can just put it on their own
domain because now we have great docs
but we still have the 30 plus different
websites everywhere
second we want to have some level of
consistency right we're not go daddy
where you can host and put anything you
want in terms of HTML and CSS we're
going to have consistency so when you go
from one product to another there's some
level of consistency so everything I'm
going to talk about is more the
technical issues that go into this I
wanted to leave one slide because as we
all know convincing people to do other
things is probably the harder part not
the technical part and convincing people
to bet on MSDN and TechNet when we
haven't been was was probably the
biggest challenge of this project and
what we did was start small we did a
pilot and showed just how much better
that 10x experience was and you got to
watch for defensiveness where it's like
I I don't want to do your thing or we
have unique requirements or maybe
they're just comfortable they don't
actually want to change the amount of
relinquish control and you have to be
aware of those things now during this
time is the Saatchi era where we're
gonna be one Microsoft and I say one
Microsoft but not ironically but I think
that was one of the challenges we wanted
to be open-source everywhere and that
was our goal because we're gonna treat
Docs just like we do code everything's
going to be open-source and there's a
lot of teams that were worried we had
general managers saying why would I want
my ducks and Amazon's going to give away
the product to be open source and you
have to get there and you have to
convince them now part of that is hearts
all those different websites that I
mentioned weren't localized how many
people English's wasn't their first
language look how many hands just take a
second there's a lot of hands up where
English wasn't their first language now
I know some of you JavaScript is
probably your first language but and I'm
so sorry for that but all these
different websites didn't have
localization so literally it was you had
to fight through English stocks and
that's really hard so we did a number of
things that I'll talk about and then
empowerment which is it's not just the
writing team that can do Docs it's our
community
it's our program manage the own people
on the teams couldn't write Docs how do
we enable it and empower anybody to
create Docs and then the other thing
which is kind of the well actually where
people will try and get you right well
what's it gonna cost all those resources
you had building websites you don't need
them anymore so put them wherever you
want it cost zero will give you better
analytics the performance is going to be
4x better 400% performance increase just
on page load will help migrate that
mother of all migrations and Jennifer
Meshkov C's team here's what our
customers are saying there's no impact
and we have 24/7 support even then
people were still hesitant and that's
why you have to listen to those other
things and this happens in any kind of
IT project when you're trying to go big
and say we're gonna unify the cusp
company towards one direction ok enough
babble let's show demos demos demos
you're all excited I'm so excited ok
what's the heart rate what are we gonna
it's at 80 oh geez okay all right can
everybody see okay folks in the back
okay I will zoom in every now and then
just to make it easy so right now we're
at the as your homepage and we build
these pages and I'm just going to go
into a piece of documentation here a
couple things to kind of call out one is
I'm gonna just drag this it works on
mobile it's responsive
it wasn't before and let me tell you
this is a filter by title so if you know
you're looking for something like
container instances it's gonna search
that tree for all the things that you
want it'll just kind of zoom in there so
you can see as I typed it actually gave
me that thing so I clicked to that page
I'm now on a page now we'll talk about
some of the different techniques here
but we have things like being able to
check is something helpful or not that
we can rate or not rates this in this
article is dynamically created based on
the h2s on the page so you as a content
developer didn't need to worry about
that you just set what the h2s are and
you're good to go
bookmark you can have bookmark pages so
it's like hey I want to remember that
how do you have all your bookmarks I'll
talk about feedback in a second but then
themes yeah dark theme we can do CSS
it's so exciting huh high contrast again
for accessibility which is a great
example of something that we can do for
inclusive design so I'm just gonna go
down the page this is all markdown but a
couple of things here what if we think
about developers what if you could
actually run code directly in a browser
do you want to download the azure if
you're doing that Pepsi challenge test
drive of a thing I'm just gonna click
try it and with the demo it's working
this is going to sign me in or it should
sign me in I'm gonna choose my account
and it's gonna create Azure cloud shell
which is basically a real shell that I
can call in the browser and I can manage
my entire asher resources and resource
groups and create resources directly
from the browser so cool okay so I'm
gonna give this a second to load and
while that's going and we'll be able to
go back there I'm also gonna click Edit
to just get that page up and going we'll
go back to our try it
and since we're nice about
there it is it's nice and ready um so
this is a real shell so um you know
that's yeah
okay that's the extent of my linux
knowledge okay um so I'm gonna click
copy as all good developers and just you
know create a resource group and maybe
we'll say my resource group five and
maybe Australia central to make it a
little closer central ok so what we've
done here is we set location Australia
central I click run and with any luck
this will actually create a resource
group name my research group five in
Australia and boom there it is created
this is in documentation I haven't done
anything I haven't downloaded anything
and we'll talk about the power of
containers but it really is environments
as a service if you have a bunch of
stuff configured a specific SDK maybe a
download of a sample app you build that
environment and now you can use it
directly in the browser okay so that's
kind of our simple example and what's
actually going on under the covers so I
clicked edit and we are in an open
source github repo and I'm going to go
ahead and click Edit and what I'll do is
this underneath the covers is the actual
contents of the file right so let's can
you all see this that okay so the title
goes in here there's metadata which is
key value pairs at the top and then it's
just markdown and when I say it's marked
and you can again just go to the preview
changes and it just shows you what the
page is gonna look like right
so how complicated is it for you to add
interactivity for that let's go down to
that you basically say back tick three
times as your CLI interactive right as
your CLI interactive it's that easy
right and at that point what we're doing
is I want to run that sample and say try
it build an experience that lets me run
code now all this is
available and we'll go through a couple
other things quickly here all using the
power of github so when you actually
made that change it's not like Wikipedia
where you make a change and all of a
sudden Dan is the President of the
United States everything goes through a
fork which is my copy and then the team
has to accept it and when they accept it
then I become the president of United
States that's how it works but the point
is if you're defacing something you're
only defacing your copy so that workflow
of I'm gonna submit a pull request and
that pull request goes through we
actually run a bunch of automation to
make sure hey is your links broken
did you forget a title did you forget a
description what's wrong with you so
those things that we all add into our CI
to make us feel really guilty about our
quality those are all within there so
this other thing that I wanted to show
was get up issues so again how do we
treat documentation as a product if you
see down here and is this helpful me
zooming in here is this yeah okay so you
see an open or closed you can open an
issue on a document piece of
documentation that opens a github issue
already right and we'll talk about what
that means but I'm just going to go
through one example hey what are the
requirements restrictions for a DNS
label you know is there a max linked
here's kind of the customer question you
can see the comments and you know he
goes back and says hey it's all
documented here so when you get stuck
one of the key things we want to do is
help you get unstuck here's the solution
you can track and it's helpful for us
right because we can say where are
people getting stuck in there's issues
we don't have this document the other
big thing was the virtuous cycle that
means hey there's some issue the link is
broken you don't have documentation for
how these labels work you'll get a
notification when we fixed it and
that'll make you much more likely to do
it again wow they're listening to me
they're actually fixing this stuff and
again you can also submit your own fixes
as well and this is all using the power
and I'll show you the great project this
is based on that does a lot of this work
for you automatically okay
so showed kind of a high-level demo
let's talk about some the architecture
what's involved in building this stuff
so this is the a chart if you will in
terms of all the things that you
typically have to go to when we're
thinking about building a solution it's
has you know to scale to millions that
are geographically diverse it has to be
up right so if something like the azure
dogs go down that would be not good for
as a career move we'll talk about the
jam zag JavaScript API is in markup on
the next page but that really is how we
get that scale and then horizontal scale
out which we're all probably familiar
with it which is hey I'm not going to
have one big massive server I'm gonna
have a bunch of stateless servers that I
can scale up or scale down as needed and
we copied that model for web hosting we
copy it for build and we even copy for
github repos that scale out model a a
couple other things is we were the very
first version before we went into that
github issues feedback that you just saw
we actually had live fire comments on
the docks and one of the issues we ran
into his life our comments actually went
down our docks didn't throw a 500 error
what we did was just basically not show
that div so how do you assume back to
the resilience how do you assume things
are gonna go down and you're okay with
that
especially in a microservices world
where you're getting data from third
parties from first parties that what
they call graceful degradation of the
experience a couple other things that
you all can see here the other one is
Akamai forward URL rewriting that is a
great tool when we have a bunch of
different teams that actually want to
use their own software but we want to
have the URL we want where basically
allows you to keep the URL you want and
in /ur / HP / whatever it can actually
point to completely different websites
so that was very helpful to kind of
control those things on that and at the
same time for file paths for URLs for
docs we just used whatever the get up
file path is so if there was a you know
as your talk to us a directory then
containers then the actual markdown file
that's the URL don't do this weird
mapping and routing it's this
simple solutions sometimes is is kind of
awesome okay and then eventual
consistency for some things like
building the PDF it can be you know take
a minute after it doesn't have to be
coupled with the link search results and
so on
okay jam stack so what this is is static
pages and I say static meaning kind of
the HTML we'll talk about exactly what
it means there fragments but it uses
dynamic dynamism through API calls and
JavaScript and we've seen this already
like you can you could argue that any
react app if you will or angular app or
any of these kind of front-end networks
kind of follows this model the
difference is really the markup which is
its created markup at Build time so it
builds these pages and as a random thing
scott called out just today about hey I
need a cloud scale database the data
changes once a month we have no money a
JSON file in cloud storage everything we
do is actually ends up being either
markdown files JSON or Gamal in file
storage we don't necessarily need a
database to store all this stuff we
don't have to pay the database cost and
it's actually way cheaper than two cents
so one click more we're all developers I
picked asp.net MVC this could really be
any sort of MVC page that follows the
same model but that's kind of the
server-side generated is on the left and
then static site generators or Jam sack
is on the right so I'm showing markdown
and liquid which is what Doc's uses
which is what Jekyll uses Jekyll being
what github built and if you're using
markdown by default on github that's
what it uses but this could be anything
there's static site generators in every
language of your choice no js' Python
asp.net I have links to them really I'm
telling you to choose jam stack which is
framework agnostic not necessarily say
use this framework this framework you
must choose view you must choose react
there's different static site generators
for both of those for example okay on
the Left we see what's called a model
which is basically a description of a
movie
it has a title release date of John rrah
we also have a Content model so this is
a really basic one which is key value
pairs key value title is QuickStart used
as your CLI date author and so on and
then the actual body which is markdown
right so when we talk about templating
what happens is the build takes this
stuff and it's going to return a model
part of the model converts this markdown
into HTML so the model includes this
thing called content which you see here
which is the actual content of the file
and then what we basically do is very
similar to here we are going to loop in
this case we're showing contributors
we're gonna loop through all the
contributors and basically display their
image we're gonna loop through every
movie and display the movie metadata
these are the same concept but and then
we spit stuff out to on the output there
here we see the title is actually
different this one ends in create a
Linux VM which is the page title is
different than the h1 which is ends with
address CLI which is the page here and
then we see our wonderful images there
here's the difference every single
request to a page this code runs every
single request once per build right
so if we are making those changes and we
figure out well we have so many changes
we our build system runs I think every
two to four seconds we're doing a new
build right and I'll talk about some of
the different things here and how we
partition those out and by the way
github if your stuff is free they'll do
the builds for you so again even the
build CPU cost will be free to you and
the hosting everything we're doing is
basically showing static content HTML on
a CDN the thing that's dynamic is of
course the most important part which is
the services the micro services
themselves so the auth the data and so
on and all that works and you're just
basically wasting CPU for what is you
know things that aren't necessarily
gonna change ok so here's kind of we did
our Quick Start howl
world markdown page now what actually
happens in github and build so I did my
fork remember we are forking we submit a
pull request it has a bunch of things
and there's a web hook into our system
and that's going to say I want you to
build the new version based on the pull
request so you can preview the pull
request in that environment what it does
it's gonna clone my Doc's run our tool
and this can be any tool that you want
in this case it's you know our document
which is what we use doctor effects
Jason being the config file that says
here's how I want this build to work the
same things we saw before it's going to
build a model it's going to apply the
template and spit out HTML fragments
into blob storage right a couple other
magic things that we have one you can
preview any branch so if people put
branches in here we do use as your
active directory so you can't
necessarily think see things that are
you know secrets that haven't launched
yet a live branch which is unique to
Docs which is really that represents
live so if you ever need to rollback you
just basically push whatever branch you
want okay we've gone we applied the
template we got one file now what's the
customer experience so we are here right
we just did the cloud build and again
these can be partitioned we can have
thousands of builds going on within here
and they're all writing to different
places in blob storage well let's start
on the left side which is a customer
visits at Azure page first we check the
cache is it hitting Akamai CDN if it is
we're just going to return the page and
not do any compute whatsoever we do have
very lightweight and this doesn't do a
lot of computation but it basically does
a lookup especially because we had to
add things like redirection and says
when I say URL just pull the HTML
fragment from this place in blob storage
and that's it and obviously we do app
insights and analytics tracking business
outcomes etc etc and a couple of other
things that we do in the liquid
templates to do things like changing
headers and so on
okay so now we have one site that we
built now that scale out model I picked
three here when you go to these three
different URLs they're actually built
from three different or more repos right
asp.net core it's completely open-source
it doesn't have the thing on the bottom
which is a private repo right anything
if you really want to follow at asp.net
core look at those branches there's a
bunch of cool stuff that I didn't even
know is shipping it's always fun to
watch but as you're you know you can
imagine before a product release they
want to be able to have you know intro
to our new service you don't necessarily
want to put that in a public so they put
it in private which is the - PR to
represent private and then at that
conference you know hey we did the
conference the Scott Guthrie's on stage
boom then we merge it back into the
public Azure docks and because these are
scaled we have thousands of these repos
the build can be scaled the repos can be
scaled and you get to use whatever repo
you want yes you have to put our config
in that but that's and that's how we get
to the level of affordability or cheaper
cost and we are like I think we saved
like seven million dollars actually it's
higher than that in terms of total costs
for this and frankly we should probably
be doing more github builds and and
facing forcing that team to pay the bill
and be a lot cheaper but the moral of
this story incredibly scalable and
Akamai CDN as your front door didn't
exist when we originally did this
project but it has over 120 different
places so your actual time to get a page
is way faster okay lessons learned so
one of the key pains that we ran into
with static site generators they build
the entire page I mean the entire page
right the problem was our team wanted to
change the chrome the outside parts and
because those were built you know you
know say twenty thousand times for each
of this page you can't change those so
what we did was have the chrome be
dynamic
and the middle red part that's what our
build system is going to do that HTML
fragment if you will that's actually you
know the actual content of the article
so the build system basically says and
and these static site generators and
again it really depends on how big a
problem you're talking about when we're
talking about 45 million docks and
people go into different pages and
they're actually different chrome that's
a problem if you have you know less than
a thousand maybe this isn't a problem at
all
but kind of to our scale and based on
this stuff do a couple the chrome from
content so we can add things like high
contrast
okay so github I mentioned and showed
the github feedback this is one of my
favorite comments it was actually from
jfl Teton Netflix when we were
interviewing and starting the new hope
he said MSDN there's no way to tell
anyone it's a black hole of feedback
that's what he called anytime there was
feedback and you'd said it on MSDN a
black and I was like I need t-shirts I
want to build a band named black hole of
feedback it was it was great and it
really helped cement what we need to do
to improve this experience for customers
so the first thing we tried was on the
Left which is live fire comments and
that ended up being a wall of text of
comments and it's really hard to track
is this comment like great job or is
there an issue in the third thread on
the seventh comment it's really hard to
track what are we used to work item
tracking right so we were able to use
get up issues as you saw before I can
define a state I can route customers is
it product feedback go here which is the
user voice so that way it can go into
that buckle and then kidding a little
you can assign users you can set labels
and I mentioned that virtuous cycle so
this is the project utterances by Jeremy
Danielle and it's available you can do
this for anything right a number of
people are using it for blogs to add
comments and again because it's github
issues it's free on the DevOps side so
our deployment you know we do CI CD all
our stuff is in github we use Azure dead
for the seei pipeline we have multiple
environments we do web app slots and
then UX automation we've done a number
of things to basically make sure there
aren't regressions that make sure that
things like our accessibility tests are
passing and so on and then one of the
key things is how we get to making
changes quickly independent deployments
so that UX templates the chrome they
ship at least daily sometimes multiple
times a day but they're not forced to
wait on the bigger train which is you
know the dock effects build engine that
can ship when it wants to and it's about
every three weeks and then every
micro-service can ship whenever it wants
to right they're completely decoupled
following a lot of the same
micro-services patterns and they have
their private data right so it's not
some shared database that we're
continuously kind of overriding our
schemas and so on get up in community
this is a number of lessons learned here
on the content side I'm just going to
show this kind of as an example but
things like your make sure you have a
code of conduct add things like the up
for grabs label when you want the
community to contribute to and so on and
so forth recognize contributors it's
really important okay you saw that large
number of hands on people that didn't
learn that English was in their first
language one of the biggest things we
wanted to do was have fantastic support
for localization so we actually support
65 plus languages including
right-to-left languages but the best
part but wait there's more
is let's say I'm a developer in Poland
I'm looking at the plpl the Polish
version of a doc there's something
incorrect
maybe there's a typo there's something
incorrect a typo and a broken link I
submit my pull pull request to the
Polish repo they fix it now polish is
fix but it cascades up so that means
English all those changes go hey the
link is broken and we're using the wrong
term in English as well so they fix
English which cascades down to every
single language so you as a Polish
developer actually improve the docs for
every single language in the world all
right I have to drop the mic now okay no
that's huge how do we make somebody's
contributions that much
more valuable by making a globe one
scale and all of this is done through
github and get of automation okay so who
cares about Docs does art do our
customers at all you know we have two
thousand public doc repositories I
mention how we scale out and that's just
in the Microsoft docs organization
there's there's many more but here's the
crazy part this is from github
October's with it's like the state of
github the number one project on all
github is Visual Studio code the number
five is Asher Docs we're better than
kubernetes yeah that's awesome
we're the fastest growing repo I
mentioned it's all those community and
ableman features that we added to be
able to do that and they're all
available and everybody can take
advantage of this it's huge and it just
shows the community wants to help each
other and help make it better and it's
beautiful sorry okay what am I now oh
god I'm like ninety okay it's so
exciting
okay API reference is really a separate
animal and what I mean by that is one
you got to remember
MSDN and TechNet we didn't even have
that great automation for dotnet we
didn't support all sorts of languages
Java Python typescript or just even the
Java Script swagger for rest API is
quantum what so we want to go from a
completely manual process that takes
weeks to automated process a Deb does
something it shows on a website in
minutes so one of the key things we did
was we built a cross language JSON
schema that basically represents how
programming languages work a programming
language that has some sort of type a
type has a name it has an input and when
you call that input it returns an output
those sort of things are common across
all programming languages some might
even have type information like you know
this is a string some might not right
they're loosely typed
so on and we call that schema document
processor it is an open specification
and we added that as well as versioning
so I mentioned the pains on Visual
Studio 2010 we added a bunch of deep
versioning support that I'll show you
and examples first so we actually just
did like a screenshot of what it's like
to go through system nut strain you had
to go down 28 page down 20 the 28th page
is the first example because there's so
many properties and methods and
signatures so what we did was basically
change it around examples first and
people love that they're like oh my god
this example is here they couldn't even
find it because after the 23rd page down
you're like alright I'm just gonna go to
stack overflow which isn't necessarily
wrong and just a couple of things when
you talk about the scale we used to be a
company that shipped every two years
every one year now like every month we
have 90,000 new releases in the last
nine months I mean I know all of you
have looked at the first 60,000 but
ninety thousand releases of new api's
that's a lot of stuff and we need to be
able to scale that out and 15 million
Doc's okay so here's what it looks like
from the pipeline one of the key things
we needed to do especially for dotnet
was our first tools and the ones that
are on dock effects today looked at
source code but we switched that to use
packages meaning using a tool that
xamarin when we had acquired xamarin
during this project we used their tool
called MDOC and i have it in the links
that looks it does a reflection based on
their dll's and their new get packages
and the reason we switched is because
source code won't tell you what things
are available in a specific release
there's a lot of times people do build
steps and say hey this API or this
method isn't going to be in dotnet
standard this one's in framework this
one's in dotnet 4 5 etc etc so there's
specific commands where you what you
really want to do is look at the output
don't start with source you're building
something this is the for 8 version this
is the Dinah core version and then look
at the api's that exists there this is
especially true when you have a lawsuit
in Europe that says you must document
your API is like some of us on stage
deal
and the package source-code this all
goes through kind of well known packages
and that schema document processor is
that one JSON file and once we get to
that thing it was really easy to do the
rest which is I now have a structure and
I'm going to apply a template just like
I did before with those that movies
model and there's other models then
another thing which is we used to have
api's everywhere every team kind of put
their own hidden thing we said if it's a
language API what if there was one place
to find all REST API is that Microsoft
or all Java ApS or all Python API is
real PowerShell we're all dotnet so
everything under every API that we ship
is under slash dot and add slash API and
then the method signature so you always
know where to go the URL is just
basically the fully qualified type and
you can see things the other key thing
how do we make this experience to
customers expect it behaves just like
intellisense so I do system dot string
and it gives me the results and I'll
show that in a second and then here's
kind of how the micro service works we
crawl all of the the source files that
are spit out by that schema document
processor throw it into cosmos DB and
our search index er which is what as
your search expects and then we have a
REST API that that Jam stack page
basically calls and says hey as I'm
typing I want you to return results ok
enough talking let's show another demo
ok so this is the Dinan API browser and
when we talk about versioning support
one of the biggest pains is I don't want
you to show me the latest I you know our
company has been on this version and I
need to be able to see this version so
just to show this all API is and this is
all eyes there's a lot of API is here
but how about just done at framework and
you get to pick which version of the API
so you know when you that trustworthy
Doc's
we know that that's the exact API that
shipped in that version so let's keep
all ap eyes and I'm just going to type
co ll and pray to the network gods and I
see
I'm gonna just increase the browser size
that better for you guys yeah
okay so I type co ll and I see a bunch
of collections some of you may not even
know that the real-time collaboration
team had their own collections or that
we had immutable collections or that we
had concurrent collections right we're
now able to see things that we didn't
even know exist it across all these
teams okay are they locking the doors
too great okay all of you are going to
submit Docs right now okay thank you for
that by the way so um let's just go look
at any specific namespace I'll let this
load and again that was calling that
REST API but we had the same experience
where you can switch versions directly
here or that same search experience
right so I'll just use system dot string
and let's go to the system nuts string
class you can of course change the
language for whatever programming
language you want and you start seeing
examples here's the cool part you can
just run this directly here let me
actually just jump to oh here's another
thing I just want to show real quick
this used to be just a wall of text of
types interfaces constructors everything
what we did was basically group them so
fields are in one place properties are
here methods are here operators are here
just those simple things to help it
easier for you to navigate those items
so I'm just gonna do a string dot format
real quick I see all the different
overloads and I see links to my examples
so I'm gonna click run here and with any
luck this will call what's called dotnet
try it another version of a container as
an environment that I can run code and
well that's going because that's going
to be a little slower than I expected
I'm going to switch over to the
addressee ally so now what we're showing
the azure CLI is a way to basically run
commands to manage Azure we have the
same capability we showed here so I'm
just going to do VM create I see that
there's a dev test lab sequel I'm going
to click
virtual machines and I see this
colorization again another open-source
project you all can use I do the try it
that we had before and there's a bunch
of examples but I'm gonna click Edit and
they said it's a little unique right
instead of going to a Microsoft dr. repo
we are going to the product so so I'm
going to say this again because it might
be a little confusing you can actually
ship code inside products you click Edit
use the exact same content that you saw
before in the examples you make a change
here you your PR you're not just fixing
our Docs you're fixing the product so
the next time the address CLI released
your samples in there if you're a
PowerShell person you can go into the
windows powershell a windows server
powershell get an example added it'll
ship in Windows it's the easiest way to
ship in Windows right this is the power
of having kind of that one source of
truth having it be open source and
making it better for everyone
so um ok so enough stall tactics and we
are we're now at a at at a code area let
me see if I can see this okay so we have
it's using string dot format you never
use string dot format you don't actually
know how to format it and I see an
example here this is ounces which is a
very American term now I went to
American public school and I know for a
fact this is kilometers sorry I made a
mistake sorry let's dollar sign of
course ok so I click run this is a
running a repple I can run code directly
in my browser you want to test an API
this is this is awesome and I'm just
gonna do you know Const let's do over
here console is intellisense in the
browser it's it's a brave new volt okay
so that's done at API is able to search
you know million every single API that
we have in one place every single
version in one place as your CLI we're
able to actually make changes into the
products are not just documentation rest
api's so if you are
using any rest api's and I'm just gonna
do a quick search for a resource this is
just another example and this is
actually gonna log me in to my a jerk
this is documentation but it's kind of
exactly what a dev needs right how do I
call this exact rest call I'm gonna log
into my Azure account I'm gonna pick the
subscription that I want to call this in
and it's gonna tell me exactly what the
many of you have used tools like postman
postman anyone ok Bueller all right good
see our hands are still working this is
postman that you can walk up and use any
API you can manage your subsidy hey let
me just test and make sure this works
and I see all the things that I built
cool ok so let's jump back to slides
whatever yeah it's ok 67 calm down which
is surprising ok marks I've learned
Aaron Rifkin and I after we had done
Docs
she joined from Amazon and she had done
training and certification there we
really wanted to kind of reimagine a
learning experience for Microsoft so we
wrote a doc kind of co-authored a doc
the same way we had done with new hope
it was like how do we reimagine the
learning experience and we had a bunch
of problems like you know incorrect and
consistent this is like frustrating for
customers I had a date the microsoft
research team built a bunch of stuff for
asher for researchers it was awesome
until it stopped working so you're a
researcher at some university you go
walk up and nothing works
you're like has your socks right and
then duplication this I charted website
dedicated to either employees partners
or customers that we duplicated content
on there's like five different academies
or universities tech academies Airmen
University imagine Academy I mean it was
just kind of on and on and on we're
literally rowing in 30-plus directions
how do we unify our approach to this but
make it that 10x better
so one of the key things that you know
there's a set of companies that do stuff
like plural cider or you know those sets
that it's learned by watching which is
you know there's a video and I'm gonna
watch all four hours of the video and
that's how I learned we were gonna do
something different we're gonna learn by
doing right when we look at people they
learn by doing they learn by breaking
things right we're also gonna do micro
learning right so each task is going to
be like five 15 minutes not this really
long thing at the same time we also want
to have learning paths so if you don't
know where to go here's your guided path
through that progress tracking
consistency this is an area where every
team said well I have an eight-hour
video that I recorded it as a user group
and I want to put on Microsoft Learn
we're not a dumping ground right like
there's a specific content model there's
a specific way that we want to do
learning and that's another area where
it's kind of hard if you will to get
people to learn learning as you're in
particular or new services required you
to have a credit card for the free
services and that was too much friction
what could we do to provide what we
called a learn sandbox you walk up click
a button yes you do have to login no
credit card you get a free environment
that lets you build the things that the
lab has and it goes away in a couple
hours it's ephemeral
this was you know how we make it that
much easier and we really want it to be
the easiest way to learn cloud we talk
about content models before one of the
key things that I'll stress is having an
information architect ours is Sarah bear
and she's phenomenal and really helped
drive this project these are her
drawings and she's an information
architect she's not a developer but she
knows how to understand and structure
data for those of you who are developers
this looks like an ER diagram right
which is I have a Learning Path it has a
connection to these things called
modules which are more like you can
almost think of modules like a course
and there's a relationship between this
so a course has specific steps which we
called units within there and there's
kind of a one-to-many relationship and
that really helped
and what are the things that we need to
do to build pages on the developer side
and get everybody to agree this is how
we're going to do it so I can do things
like filter all courses for a specific
just beginner or just IT or just DevOps
or just security so here's how it works
coding so instead of kind of the
markdown for actual steps the actual
content is still marked down but now we
needed a new way to basically build
these pages and you can think of this
almost like a JSON database or in this
case a yeah mol database which is these
are all the key value fields we have
things like hey a title can't be blank
an MS date has to be a date time and so
on and so forth and using this you can
build that page by saying hey page dot
title is going to go here page dot
levels roles products those are all
going to be tags so I'm actually going
to include them all up here in a list
right so it allowed a kind of that
representation the team can work on the
template the other team can work on the
data model and we're kind of unblocked
and this is another area where we need a
lot of micro services right so progress
profile hierarchy sandbox and so on and
the same kind of learning environment
and the point is this is all static HTML
just like we saw before the HTML
fragments but we're calling dynamic
services couple other things we saw two
examples here I didn't want to just call
them out TriNet is stateless so every
request compute stuff and returns could
be stuff in returns Azure cloud shell is
actually stateful so if you're looking
for kind of ways that you think about
for building apps okay let's get into
demos give this a second okay so this is
an example Learning Path and you can see
we have tags we have all the different
modules or courses that we can do and
you can do this step by step
I had the connected app to Azure storage
one that I've done before
you can look at kind of the steps within
here and there's a metadata across all
these three and these things called
exercises I'm gonna see if my sandbox is
available again you can choose kind of
your programming language here I'm gonna
wait for that to finish loading come on
shell this is my sandbox which I
activated about two hours ago and we
only let you have four per day primarily
for our security and a couple of other
things that we did there so you know you
aren't Bitcoin mining okay so not not
you this wonderful crowd it's those
other people are that Damion Brady guy
okay so this by the way is real code so
we can build our app here right dotnet
new console and I'm just kind of
following along there and I'll just call
it photo sharing app - I don't know
we'll go with that this is going to go
and and by the way the cloud shell has
dotnet installed it has node installed
it has Java installed we could clone a
project and be effectively use this as a
cheap coding environment so I'm going to
do code dot and go into our photo
sharing app - whoa I'm writing code
awesome for int I equals zero is less
than 10 you guys are like my visual
winters so if I'm doing something wrong
okay so and hello NDC all right so I'm
gonna click file save and you know I can
just exit this it's kind of one example
and what did we say CDA photo sharing
app - I did give the achievement for
this by the way and just gonna say done
it run come on baby
if anybody's so nervous okay so well
this is actually ready hey all right wow
I can do a for-loop row but if you're
learning like how do we just reduce the
barriers to do that so I'm going to
scroll down here and go to the next step
here and just copy paste this example
and the one thing it is looking for is a
name so let's say my live demo and I'm
gonna click enter now a couple things I
really want to call out we're
dynamically changing that massive gooood
is the sandbox we built so we actually
tokenize the code samples so that way
you can copy paste even easier right so
it's like I know that you have access
I've given you permission to the sandbox
that goes away you can log into the
azure portal you can do this code sample
inside Visual Studio code or whatever
product service that you want you
actually have access to it for four
hours and we're gonna change the sample
to make it reusable now the other thing
that we did was how do we check your
work a lot of times people and learning
sites they have multiple choice quizzes
which we do but wouldn't it be cool if
we could actually check your work so
what we do is we walk up to that
subscription that we have access to and
again it's a separate subscriptions that
way in case you delete everything you're
not deleting production right happened
you click check your work and only if
you actually wrote your code correctly
do you get the achievement right that's
cool we're all using Azure resource
manager here are the steps that we want
to do we're validating whether you've
done it correctly and then we unlock the
Chivo okay so we have a few minutes left
I do want to talk about some of the
things that we learned and one of the
other key areas that we do here all
right so Jam sack is revolutionary it
really is the best way to do a number of
things there's so many times when you
can just get away with having JSON and
Yambol as your database and github as
opposed to paying for C
we'll server when you don't necessarily
need it or when you're not changing data
that much and even then like I said
we're changing millions of Doc's and
we're doing millions of releases and
it's still scales for our specific needs
another key area is while we talk about
technology if you're doing this you
could build your own documentation site
with localization with interactive
components in a one-day hackathon and
make it that much better put it all on
github and and the key thing is people
are going to be like well why are we
doing this show them the data on why
people care about this and why it's
important and sometimes is important for
external customers but the most ignored
developers are inside the firewall which
is I had to take a dependency on this
team they don't have any documentation
I'm looking through their code and of
course every other team is an idiot's
right so the more you can help each
other the better you can build kind of
that community of helping each other
there's a learning curve for a github
get and markdown you shouldn't dismiss
this especially for your writers the
less technical your writers are like
again we now have IT Pro content for how
to you know set up Microsoft teams those
writers aren't necessarily developers
I'll show you some tools that exist that
are free that will help there a couple
other things our address DK is six
gigabytes because we continuously change
the images and screenshots the actual
content is 50 Meg's of markdown right so
if you have a lot of images don't put
the images inside get up get up is a
terrible place for binaries in general
it would be great to use a tool like
cloud an area that makes this a lot
easier or you know your own separate
thing this is one of our lessons learned
where your git clone now takes like 15
minutes because it's taking all images
that you won't need from you know 2007
where if we just did the 50 Meg's
it's I don't know under 10 seconds 10
minutes versus 10 seconds and too deep
did this great paper on it but
unfortunate we didn't get approval to do
it I mentioned some of these before and
also some ends good enough is good
enough the time to read calculation I
think it's like number of words divided
by a fraction it's good enough we didn't
have to build an AI model that you know
tracks people's progress to do this so
it's good enough and you know I think
we've adjusted it maybe
it's always assumed people are gonna
misuse your stuff when you're building a
platform how do you do that people
started adding HTML and CSS and broke a
bunch of our accessibility tools find
guardrails to basically sanitize
anything they do a Content lifecycle so
those old versions of visual studio or
on this thing dr. Markovic on previous
versions no Windex no fallout you can
still search when you're in previous
versions but that way Google and the
visual studio 2012 problem where that
thing has awesome Google juice goes away
sweat the details so how we organize
types in the Left TOC performance is a
fantastic detail inclusive design and so
on and dachshund learn our team sport so
[Music]
again where we started was 30 different
websites or even more no automation no
anything and this is kind of where we
are now culture change at Microsoft
isolation to openness stepping up their
game and even just simple things like
our twitter account which by the way has
double the number of Twitter followers
than I do which is sad people low-key
love it and and that's Dan Delamar ski
and cheer Goldberg right and just people
when we made the PowerShell sample this
is such a cool feature this you're
making it way too practical these days
brilliant idea interactive jocks are
simply next-level right this is really
powerful and it's a lot easier than you
can imagine
okay so resources all put this up I
mentioned the static site generators
this is the jam hsiao homepage this is
the scoreboard if you want to see all
the different static site generators
that exists and how many stars what
languages they use on the left side
what's the programming language that
they use and then what it on the right
side is what's the template language so
depending on what you want to do you can
kind of pick and then I mentioned the
syntax highlighter Duncan's project our
Docs authoring pack which makes it
really easy M doc doc Tanner's which is
the easiest way to get reference for all
languages that Den does as well and the
last thing I want to show you was while
we close is
just a quick demo because people say I I
don't know how to use github or I don't
want to learn markdown there are tools
that make this really easy right so I'm
using this is natla 5cms I'm gonna add a
new doc article it adds a title hello
hello world has never been so hard to
spell
okay um pound and this is rich text
right this is my title list list list
right so you don't need to know markdown
to do this right but if you want to you
get a preview on the right that you can
actually this is customizable so you
could apply your own skin or if you
really do like using markdown you can
switch between these views now the key
here we're gonna click Save this is
nothing more than a stat what they call
headless CMS it's a static page that
uses JavaScript to write to github so
what we've just done is we built a pull
request did I need to do a know all the
knowledge of what a pull request is or
how to build one know me as my content
team and this is another area it has a
Kanban board where you can see what are
the workflow entries and those are all
the entries saved and I'm able to see
kind of the editorial workflow and this
should have the one I just launched in
and again it's logging on to my account
underneath the covers this is doing
nothing more than doing rights and pull
requests to a repo right so I see pull
requests used to be four and five I just
built this 34 seconds ago it does all
this stuff for me so if you have folks
that are looking get-ups you hard get up
not for me use the power of github and
use the front-end to make it really easy
and you're able to easily this is gonna
be the hardest part dragging dropping
that article and publishing the new
article and that publishing a new
article means something to editorial for
us it means we're taking a PR and
merging it into master right underneath
the coverage we didn't have to worry
about and you can add all the the
wonderful things that you want they're
incredibly powerful and totally open
source so I just wanted to end and say
thank you all for attending appreciate
it I'll be around for questions as well
and we're passing a tip jar it's called
green squares that I think you you put
in the bottom and every time I get to
work another day at Microsoft so please
put those in there thank you all